i am super comfortable being single i i
am the slightest bit like i love my
friends i love my life like i'm finally
at a point where i'm actually don't like
need amanda i'm like i'll adopt from i
don't get from i don't give a shit like
i'm kind of i'll have a kid with elon
musk even though my eyes aren't far
apart enough for him
does anyone know why all the girls he
dates have such goldfish heads
am i wrong
he wants them to look like aliens yeah
do you need all his girls to have
peripheral vision like what is the
what is his yeah i'm so curious his
philosophy on that like with the kids
also you know there's like a hundred
thousand kids that he's got a lot in
foster care right now that could really
use a home yeah and we don't need a bu
but it's nice you also want to make your
own too i get that i know it's like
buying a dog from a breeder but you can
rescue a couple do you like rescuing
like there's one of the dogs that's in
here that's terrifying like well you're
a new yorker you guys are scared of like
very easy no no you have one that has a
strong neck
and it just walks around and it is the
scariest fucking thing i've ever i don't
even feel comfortable petting it it's
like at any point in time if it bites
down on me it's taking me wherever it
wants to go and you have it just walking
around your nice chic fucking home in
the middle of goddamn nowhere wherever
we are i don't think the dog i think the
dog was here first i don't think that
you adopted the dog i think you built
the house around the dog and the and
here's the thing i'm scared of it this
is just a giant dog
when i came here i was like where are
the dogs like oh they're in cages and
i'm like good like finally this is the
first time i felt comfortable in your
home and then about five minutes ago
that dog walked by that door right there
and i haven't been the same since
you just started talking about how much
you love your dad yeah i was like i need
i need something something i need
something to happen
yeah i was like okay we got it i think
we got it i think it's ramona the
ridgeback
the ridgeback oh that means alex is here
oh alex is here yeah so that dog
yeah that dog needs to be uh
that it needs to be put down sorry my
dog is not like a fucking paddington
bear
doodle fucking doodle fucking we've
we've made the snickerdoodle what they
need to be
like that dog is more like what before
humans got around
that dog is closer dog
are we on the same page finally yes
it seemed like we're agreeing you you
know that the guy that made uh is it a
doodle a labradoodle yeah look i just
want to let you know right now the guy
made labradoodles has publicly stated
that it was a mistake i know i know and
he is sorry but here's the other thing i
don't care when that bites you in the
face in three years no no no no no no no
it doesn't
that thing right there
at any point you this is what you don't
know like you're gonna have one of your
little soirees where everybody does
pagan rituals and whatever and like
drinks fucking blood or whatever you
fucking weirdos do out here
and
that dog is gonna fucking tear up
people's necks
i mean this and it's gonna happen and
and then we're gonna go back to this
process we're looking for an excuse to
get a facelift that is the perfect i
gotta attack my wedding face her face
new face dog attacked me i have pimples
around so that when i get a facelift i'm
like oh no it's just reconnecting just
reconstruction
just pet the dog you pet the dog and the
dog looks at you like are you fucking
dumb like why would you do this like
you're putting your hand closer to my
biting thing
it is the scariest dog i've ever been
around in my life the last time i was
here not only did you have it just
roaming around free unleashed with no
muzzle
you gave me food in front of it
and it sat next to me
looking at me and it was it was staring
at me and it was just going like i'mma
let you finish this sandwich but if i
wanted i'd just take that whole fucking
thing
it was like you didn't put it away
or anything and that that is your
problem
you have an issue uh-huh you have an
issue right right
you have an issue okay i'm gonna come
back here and i'm gonna i'm being
serious you think i'm joking no no i
don't there there will be a zebra here
within three years
animals like no no no you have weird
things with animals you you went to try
to save a giraffe from a fire yes that's
right that's right i got it out it took
three years got it out if it couldn't
see the fire coming
[Laughter]
if there's one animal that could have
nodded to the rest of the animals
that the fire was coming it's that
giraffe maybe it didn't want to be
around anymore maybe that maybe the
giraffe saw the fire and it was just
like finally thank god i don't have to
be at the winery anymore where people
are spitting fucking cabernet on me all
day as they pet my fucking hooves and
then it was you
with your with your stupid water
moccasins or whatever you went down
there where it's time to save the
giraffe i'm here we got it it was the
book of eli you were you were in your
fucking denzel washington book of eli
outfit with a patch you wore one eye
patch for some reason and you were
trying to steal a giraffe listen i need
you to get it together
[Music]